let's uh i i want to make this
announcement now guys because we're
moving on from censorship we have this
tweet from me oh oh i am excited to
announce that teamcast.com is now
officially hosted on rumble videos cloud
services and video hosting this is step
one in utilizing and building more
resilient infrastructure for
communication amid the culture war and
mass censorship
big news just happened
paypal banned a bunch of independent
media outlets matt taibbi wrote about it
the new york post picked it up this is
terrifying and we don't know why
russian disinformation or some other
nonsense
when they come out
with this disinformation governance
board
that they mayorkis was like it's not
going to target americans no i'll tell
you what's going to happen they're going
to say
the story about you know biden is
russian disinformation
then paypal and other financial services
will ban independent media outlets that
are are talking about or sharing the
story considering we we did an article
deep diving into the pfizer data that we
can't talk about on youtube i think it's
fair to say that the powers that br are
going to be not too happy with what our
website is doing however
our web services are now hosted by
rumble
while i'm i don't think rumble is
completely invulnerable or perfect it's
way better than being on amazon google
or any other you know host that's going
to be in silicon valley and going to
have all these weirdo crackpot rules so
one thing we did is this we've got a
bunch of other stuff happening we're
currently working on but we're
announcing it as it comes so
step one get the website off of big tech
silicon valley there we go it's part of
a different kind of cabal that's forming
but at least it's market competition at
least we're supporting someone who's
giving the middle finger for now to
amazon web services in the future rumble
may become the biggest they may be
amazon web services but as long as
there's competition things are getting
better
chris talks a lot about chris pavlaski
the ceo of rimmel talks a lot about open
sourcing stuff and decentralizing
servers i'm 100 on board with
decentralizing servers when you talk
about open sourcing stuff that's great
but the proof is in the pudding my man
open source the code free the software
go agpl3
yeah we don't talk about this enough
right but aws and the hosts who allow
people to keep their websites up they
have a tremendous amount of power we
generally look at the big tech companies
like youtube and facebook twitter the
ones that really allow you to get
exposure but you should be able to have
a website as sort of an escape hash so
you can direct your fans there in case
you do get banned but then it's the case
that like you said amazon could end up
taking you and and the other risk is um
we use paypal
you know a lot of people said they don't
like it and they didn't want to use it
and i know simply by talking about what
paypal has done to these independent
reporters and personalities we run the
risk of putting ourselves on their radar
and they gave no justification for why
they banned these people and in one
instance i believe they said they're
seizing the assets to see like to decide
what what to do with it they've done
that with bank accounts too though chase
was banning conservatives i believe
laura loomer was kicked off a chase
banking there's so many of them that
they can't even bank they can't she
couldn't use comcast services for her
ads i believe
so it's
it's far-reaching and that's just the
free market at work and it's acceptable
but elon musk buying twitter is fascism
mm-hmm
yes yep thanks robert reich so we got to
do we got we got to do a lot to to um
continually expand our infrastructure
the first step was um we're definitely
looking at
payment processors we're looking at
video like we're so we're using rumble's
video hosting for all our member stuff
we're using rumble's cloud services
the next thing we got to look at is
payment infrastructure but the reason we
did this first was if they take the
website down like any anyone in the
chain says we're not going to service
you we're not going to link your domain
any whatever
we're not going to provide you hosting
site's gone
financials we lose money but we'll
figure something out the next step is to
secure this system and then we will be
much more resilient we got paypal stripe
uh stripe i don't know if stripes on the
site right now stripe is our primary and
then did you mention the other one the
wrong we don't have any any other one um
i think cryptos is very promising for
the future you know they finally started
taxing it properly for the most part so
you can kind of get away with using it
for payments
um and then you don't have to dabble
with the fiat at all you still gotta pay
taxes on it but uh i think that's that's
really really good it's all digital all
the time
and um
uh the swift payment system can't mess
with it at least
overtly yeah
so here's my question tim when we look
at rumble we look at these other
services is there a better way to do
this eventually that we could you know
imagine down the line where there isn't
some centralized service you have to go
to in order to be hosted
yeah you want to decentralize something
look at ian
you were talking about mesh networking
which is where all of our devices are a
piece of the server and if one goes down
the server's still up because all the
other pieces are working together uh it
works near near frequency right now you
can get things like noster and ostr
there's another one called briar i think
services where you can communicate when
it's not on the internet you don't need
an internet you have a local net
that's kind of the future if we can
somehow link up some sort of global mesh
net you know tesla was working on
sending electricity through the ocean
and underground to people so we may be
able to wi-fi each other oh you mean
actual tesla nikola tesla yeah and so we
may be able to to communicate with each
other through ground i thought you're
talking about elon musk i was like
imagine you're swimming in the ocean you
get zapped
he was obsessed with sending electricity
which was really kind of hard i think
that was hurting stuff and causing
crazy you know amorphisms in the
environment but like that what do you
mean uh like he would cause he caused an
earthquake one time in lower manhattan
yeah did he really help anyone yeah no
no nikola tesla oh it was like in the
early 1900s and they went down to his
office like what's going on dude they
came and eventually shut them down
because it was too much they shut down
his uh
his uh what's it called
warden cliff his big tower where he's
trying to project wireless electricity
around uh i don't know if he was
damaging stuff with that but they don't
know it sounds like he might have been
you ever heard the story about that dude
who made the radioactive death ray in
his garage no yes yes i did
what's the element called americium
i don't know
amer american i don't know how you
pronounced it the word america he was
like collecting smoke detectors and then
using the little radioactive bits and
putting it inside like a container
and then it would focus the beam and
then he was like covered in radioactive
like lesions
yeah what part of that seemed like a
good idea though well on the part where
you'd end up having a death rate yeah
i guess was he where was he what was he
gonna do well that's wild i know that
it's wild
maybe like the neighbor's cat kept
coming over bothering him i guess the
government found out offered him a job
but then he kept making death rays so
they just eventually arrested him what
did they think he was gonna do what it
what did they think he was gonna do i
don't know but like dude with the death
rush well it's just like you made a
death ray here's a bunch of money you
made more death rays for shame no no
think about it they found a guy who made
a focused like radioactive beam
that's silent silent assassination you
know you could like be in a cafe and
like point it at some guy and yeah it
looks like it was a aram american
american 241 is the chemical
yeah death death ready people at the
cafe tim wikipedia calls him a radio uh
nuclear radiation enthusiast who built a
homemade neutron source at the age of
17. holy crap
he died from the death ray i'm not sure
he died in 2016 so it could have been
from multiple different things but i'm
assuming the radiation poisoning heads
david
david radioactive boy scout or the yeah
if i die and my name
scout that'd be is
yeah this is in 2007.
yeah oh this is second time this is kind
of a second neutral yeah he did it when
he was 17. he's found in his freezer
crazy
larceny of smoke detectors
in michigan he was allegedly removing a
number of smoke attackers detectives
from the halls where were his parents
right seriously
oh that's just a little timmy building
radioactive death racism
i think i think if you can build a
radioactive death way you could death
right you could probably escape your
parents view you know yeah probably
that's fair that's fair point but his
death was ruled as an accidental result
of intoxication from the combined
effects of alcohol diphedra uh diet
phenhydramine yeah diphenhydramine
fentanyl yikes
i don't remember where i read the story
but i remember reading it they said his
mug shot he was covered in legions yeah
so somehow we were talking about
fighting censorship now we started
talking about nikola tesla yeah
transmitting energy we're talking about
mesh network
if we could build a stabilized mesh
network i i'm really interested in the
idea of sending wi-fi underground
through the ground that'd be really do
you think the effects of wi-fi
everywhere would be them man
i feel like it's not good for us i think
it's driving people
wacky like squirrely i think it's
heightening people's tension
it's like you think that's why all the
time and your brain starts to get like
really yeah you're uh yeah i think
that's part of it diet and and
uh frequency
yeah that might be i don't i've not seen
a lot of evidence about it though but it
just feels like it like different
studies about how the rays affect like
women's reproductive systems and stuff
but i don't think we're ever going to
know for a very long time well it's all
non-ionizing radiation i would carry my
phone in my left pocket from the age
from like 2000 to 2014 and all of a
sudden one day it started getting really
sore my leg right where i took when i
had it took it out for like three days
and it was no longer sore i'd no longer
carry this thing in my pocket i never
never never unless i have to get it
somewhere i did the reasonable thing and
i carry myself one of my underwear yeah
that's the way to go yeah that's good
yeah
no problems
no no no no no no no no that'll keep you
safe yeah that'll protect you from the
beanie
i always actually wondered about that
because when i was on the ground doing
reporting i would wear it on my chest
and the camera would be rolling it'd be
clipped to my chest and i'm like if i
ever get cancer
yeah but it's like you have heart cancer
but i feel like we're not we're not
capable of operating as a species
without all this stuff anymore there's
no way for us to disconnect now we went
to disagree we went to um we were coming
back from nashville we went we stopped
and we stayed at this beautiful like
place overlooking this waterfall but
there's no wi-fi and it was really
concerned like i was really like upset
for the night kind of i was like how
will i what am i even worried about like
how will i what fill in the blank how
will i connect with you yeah like just
connect with nature man the waterfall
smells great thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there